nobody's gonna bet you cannot ever quit
Jerry
two fighter five upholds the series
likes offering a diverse cast of
characters that brings it's great
fighting engine to life some of its
predecessors iconic mechanics have been
retired in favor of new ones that add to
the distinct qualities of each character
stripping away universal actions in
favor of specialized skips combat in
Street Fighter 5 feels refined and more
honed in than before but when you aren't
fighting with a friend by your side or
over the Internet
cracks elsewhere begin to show there's
an apparent lack of modes some of which
have been around since street fighters
early years but more importantly there's
almost no way someone without a hardcore
competitive spirit it managed to parse
the game's fighting styles and move
lists and the potential strategies these
elements introduced one of the most
notable differences between Street
Fighter 5 and its predecessor is the
removal of the focus attack which was an
easily executable move by which any
character could absorb incoming attacks
and subsequently dish out a heavy hit
that temporarily stunned their opponent
it was a tool that seemed to be designed
for casual players allowing them to mix
up the flow of a fight at a moment's
notice but in practice it ultimately
slowed down fights and contributed to
the watered-down feeling of the game's
cast as it was available to every
character spear Fighter 5 doesn't have a
direct replacement for the focus attack
but it definitely has an answer for
people who bemoaned a negative impact it
had on the pace of fights in Street
Fighter 4 now every character has access
to three V abilities outside of their
standard attacks these skills
be reversals and be traitors these
skills can be used at any time and these
grant each character different but
equally useful capability reuse v-skill
is one of the most iconic as he can use
it to parry an incoming attack a
throwback to the universal parry
mechanic from Street Fighter 3 V
reversals require a subunit of the V
meter and they allow block and character
to break free from an onslaught to bring
the fight back to their opponent
lastly V triggers grant character is a
special temporary buff that enhances
their abilities though again it varies
by character the variety introduced by
these via bilities ensures that fights
stay interesting giving each character a
particular means of getting into or out
of the fight other more subtle tweaks
contribute to Street Fighter fives
unique feel
while characters take some damage from
an incoming hit while blocking known as
chip damage you only die while blocking
if you're hit with a critical arts
attack the game's version of a cinematic
super movie in the past a diligent
fighter could die from a series of fast
and cheap hits even though they were
blocking now that that's no longer the
case the final moments of a fight are
far more tense than ever for every move
and every mistake apparently
budding within this system feels great
and three fighter five delivers tense
one-on-one fights either in person or
online
Capcom servers weren't great at launch
but they are mostly stable now one
weekend there isn't much else for the
average player to do in Street Fighter 5
challenge and trial modes are coming to
Street Fighter 5 but they aren't
available yet meaning that anyone who
wants to learn how to play with skill
must brave intimidating online battles
and do their best to pick apart move
lists for now you can fight people on
and offline engage with the laughably
short and low-quality story mode and try
to survive as many fights as possible
against the cpu and survival mode and
that's about it
the story mode offers a few fights in
narrative tidbits harbour character but
you can complete all of them in less
than an hour total at least the server's
seem to be working now in Street Fighter
5s net code is largely great but if you
ever find yourself fighting against
someone with an average connection or
lower the choppiness that ensues renders
a fight pointless as the framerate
becomes erratic and both players
frantically attack in hopes of landing a
blow and into chaos Street Fighter 5 has
a long road ahead of it and this is just
the beginning it has one of the best
fighting engines around and the
distribution of abilities among the cast
makes for a diverse and well-balanced
fighting system but despite playing like
a dream Street Fighter 5 needs more
modes for people to sink their teeth
into not only for fun but to learn
enough to have a fighting chance against
other players for anyone other than the
most hardcore competitors Street Fighter
5 is delightful teams
you